many animals possess a magnificent
ability to control their appearance
especially cephalopods like the octopus
seen here by changing the color contrast
and texture of their skin these animals
create dynamic patterns on their bodies
to both blend in and stand out in their
environments the color-changing
capabilities of these wondrous creatures
have been the subject of fascination for
many researchers but have not yet been
replicated in synthetic systems I'm dr.
Stephen Morin a material scientist
working in the rapidly developing field
of soft machines in which we fabricate
synthetic systems using soft polymers
and flexible reinforcing sheets my
colleagues and I inspired by
color-changing cephalopods have created
soft robots with dynamic coloration and
contrast our approach combines
microfluidics pattern and color to not
only provide robots with camouflage or
display properties but also to propel
them colors and patterns are manipulated
by pumping colored or temperature
controlled fluids through a network of
microfluidic channels embedded in a thin
flexible silicon sheet called the color
layer the motion of these quadrupedal
Walker's is driven by the pneumatic
pressurization and inflation of micro
channels embedded in elastic polymers a
typical soft quadrupeds can move at
close to 40 metres per hour the color
layers are light and flexible enough to
be compatible with these stretching
machines without hampering their
movement color layers can be patterned
in many ways in this example the color
layer was given large disjointed patches
of contrasting colors to match its
variable environment
but camouflage is only one application
of color control mechanisms that can
make robots stand out against their
backgrounds are also useful for example
bright and contrasting colors can aid in
the location and recovery of machines
from poorly lit environments here you
can see a demonstration of fluorescent
and chemiluminescent solutions
camouflage and display can also be
manipulated in the infrared spectrum
through the use of temperature
controlled colorants in this
demonstration a robot is being displayed
in both the visible and infrared
spectrum the ability to control both
visible and infrared signatures is rare
in nature due to the limitations that
most organisms have in controlling their
own body temperatures these systems
provide the first steps toward imitating
the dynamic and complex color changing
functions of cephalopods they are
accessible and could be useful in many
disciplines such as the study of
camouflage use in nature and to
realistically simulate fluid vessels and
muscle motion